you guys recently put out an arc a brand
new monthly update for Bitcoin and you
also talk a little bit about the merge
the cosplays and the supply starts to
shift when you have that crossover event
it's very reliable for suggesting a
general area let's talk about the merch
it imposes the terrorists in the whole
system but transition from proof of work
to people stay we expect that narrative
to be very in favor of ethereum is it
just that the macro environment is kind
of the most important thing right now
the macro has become extremely if not
the most valuable source of information
for determining Bitcoin and crypto price
action as well when you begin to look at
how derivative Traders are handling the
merge how are Traders actually playing
this all right guys bang bang I've got
David here uh David you guys recently
put out at ARC uh a brand new monthly
update for Bitcoin uh and you also talk
a little bit about the merge and I
thought a great place that we could
start with some of the on-chain
analytics which you're very very
familiar with
um and when we go ahead and we take a
look at these on-chain uh analytics you
can see that the 200 week moving average
continues to serve as kind of this great
point of support for bitcoin's Price
talk a little bit as to why this is so
important and why you guys continue to
evaluate this
well you can look at it on uh through
several lenses
um and it's it's in essence a four-year
Trend you know related to the housing
cycle
which is a hypothetically a very
important time Horizon for Bitcoin and
therefore all crypto
um historically that you know the first
instance of the 200-week moving average
was around 20 2015 I believe and it has
marked reliably bottoms for
um all the Cycles in Bitcoin so far
and including uh you know major crashes
like the covet meltdown in 2020. so it's
a very important all the technical
metric a very important metric for us to
keep just track of a general uh status
of the overall Market structure and
primary trend and then when we look at
something like the Bitcoin investor cost
basis one of the things that's
fascinating to me is the investor cost
basis was actually higher a couple of
months ago but it's trended down as the
price has come down and Bitcoin still
sits above that uh current investor cost
basis talk a little bit about the
importance of that serving as support
and also uh that it is a moving Target
right it doesn't just kind of always go
up in these situations it does go down
and why that's important as well
right so the investor cost basis is
calculated as follows right
um you take realized cap which is the
general cost basis of the market uh
meaning you aggregate the all coins at
the point with where each last moved or
was last thought right and then from
that you subtract uh thermal cap
or thermal price which is in essence the
cumulative
um sum of minor Revenue through time so
what you're basically doing is capturing
the actual Delta
in all moved coins and subtracting minor
activity out of your question uh and
what what you're left with is actual
investor cost basis which if you see the
graph there is uh reliable for marking
um bottoms throughout the history of
Bitcoin uh now importantly we are we
have touched that threshold twice in the
last few months
uh it's currently at 19 000 and change
um so it's it's very important to us
from our first principles and also the
battle tested
um backward looking basis to determine
um a potential bottom for the cycle
uh given that investors would like to
defend that uh level uh severely
um given it's important
got it and then if we look at the long
term versus the short-term uh cost basis
here those seem to be crossing over and
I know that you guys call out in the
report that that tends to Mark a
cyclical bottom
yeah
um so sometimes you want to look for a
specificity in terms of timing on when
to let's say look for bottom or or
whatever approximate approximation to
that
uh so I'll first go through explaining a
little bit of what determines a
short-term holder or the short-term
holder cost basis and the long-term
holder equivalent of that
long-term holders
or the coins of that cohort are
basically the Bitcoins that
haven't moved in 155 days or more and
conversely short-term holders are coins
or Supply that has been moved in the
last 155 days now this number is not
arbitrary it's actually quite important
given the history of Bitcoin there's
some statistical analysis that has been
done on the metric that determined that
that 155 threshold and it varies from
analyst to analysts sometimes it's on 40
I've seen iterations on 120 but for
overall that six to five to six month
time Rising is very important because
uh historically the probability of a
single coin moving after that 155 day
threshold uh drops severely to let's say
less than three percent overall so
dormancy of coins in Bitcoin have a
Lindy effect and that Lindy effect
um goes exponential
after that uh 155 day Horizon so what we
do here is determine okay we have our
respective Supply coords long-term
holder shorter molder and then we we
assign a cost basis to each
uh and what we found
um
going back to the three last major cycle
so Bitcoin is that whenever
um the short-term holder cost spaces
which is usually higher than the
long-term holder cost basis
um because it's packed with speculators
and that sort of uh Market actor
um when that important holder cost basis
goes below the long tube holder one it
marks a very
um
reliable
um bottom uh sticky now our assumption
from first principles is that this
happens because
um
the market has reached an equilibrium
between speculators and actual long-term
holder
um Market participants and also um the
cost base and the supply straps starts
to shift from
um
um short-term holder activity and
holding into the long-term holder
bracket
um as you can see in the in the chart
when you have that crossover event it's
very reliable not only for suggesting a
general area of a bottom but also like
precisely picking out timing
environments where you can um you know
upgrade your your bullish conviction now
this goes we're matching this chart to
to the following one which would be the
long-term holder Supply and we're
already seeing
um
this take to take effect from another
perspective so what you're seeing here
is the long-term holder Supply
um which is about
um it's about 70 percent of total
outstanding Supply today
um
uh as of um as of the publication of uh
Bitcoin monthly it hadn't reached
all-time highs it's now uh uh brand new
all-time highs
um which is uh increases the convection
on overall you know being you know the
the supply getting squeezed uh getting a
liquid and becoming even more inelastic
now uh go going back to the the
crossover event at the publication of
the Bitcoin monthly a few days ago
that number the Delta between short term
holder and long-term holder was about uh
2500 dollars now it's about about 900 so
it's you know coming up fast when you
think about uh this long-term holder
Supply we continue to see it reach close
to if not all-time highs we're closing
in on 14 million Bitcoin being held by
long-term holders uh obviously only 21
million ever there's about 19 million or
so that are out into a circulation uh is
there a point where there becomes
concern about Bitcoin being too illiquid
like just nobody will spend it and
everyone's just holding it long term uh
and so like the number could get too
high or is it just classic number go up
technology and the more people are
holding the less liquid the market the
more increase in demand it leads to a
price increase in the future
this episode is brought to you by Ledger
the best crypto Hardware wallet
everyone's heard the phrase not your
keys not your coins and that's more true
today than it's ever been ultimately a
value proposition of Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies is self-custody where
you get to retain ownership over your
digital assets that is what Ledger
specializes in they've got multiple
pieces of hardware and they also have
the Ledger live mobile app which makes
it seamless to not only retain control
over your Bitcoin but also allows you to
interface with exchanges lending
platforms and other types of software
products if you're interested in upping
your self-custody game go check out
Ledger today
shop.ledger.com again that's
shop.ledger.com go check them out and
start doing self-custody you'll thank me
later
there is some truth to that latter
statement but um
regardless of anything we expect a
general
um equilibrium in the market between
um several factors one is issuance being
less and less over time uh we'll know
that part so therefore the asymptotic
curve in total circular in Supply over
time we all seen that chart very
familiar with that uh but most
importantly other factors are
you know show some interesting signals
so for instance there's less
issuance coming into the system but
there's been less coins being lost
because they're more valuable over time
right so that increases a little bit the
the
liquidity of Bitcoin overall
uh and on top of that
um both a liquid and long-term holder
supplies
um
are are increasingly
um
so basically is this you're having less
issuance over time
in addition you're having less lost
coins so that increases a little bit uh
the the overall number of coins that
could be traded at any given time but on
top of that given that uh Bitcoin is
more valuable a liquid and long-term
Supply are also being increased over
time given that Bitcoin has more value
historically so the market is actually
noticing that
um and they're losing less coins but
they're saving them instead which is a a
very important observation that I think
most people are not aware of
and then if we go and we look at uh the
eth BTC trading pair do you guys
explicitly call this out as having
outperformed Bitcoin talk a little bit
about the trading pairs in general why
is this one so important and then what
is the significance of it having
outperformed something like Bitcoin
yeah so let's talk about the merge
despite that the report is called a
Bitcoin monthly right
um the impact of ethereum in the overall
crypto market and therefore relative
um price action to bitcoin is pretty
much uncontested right now
um and what we've seen as you see in the
chart there is starting in more or less
2021 a trading a trading range has been
established in the BTC pair and hasn't
not left that uh trading pair so far now
the upper bound with that trading pair
is very near
um
the the all-time highs seen in at the
latest 2020 2018 I believe
um so we're we're watching that break
Break Up breakout in case it happens in
terms of the merge is a narrative and
also a fundamental event for the history
of ethereum
um if of course it it imposes the tail
risk in the whole system but uh
expecting success on the um
transition from proof of work to proof
of stake we expect that narrative to
um be very in favor of ethereum and
therefore overall crypto sentiment and
the technology that blockchain
Technologies as a whole uh so we're
keeping an eye on that there's a lot of
talk of you know the merge being a
solvenience or in this case saw the
event
event
um so we're keeping a close eye on that
um watching how price action behaves
relative to such an important uh
occurrence
when you begin to look at how derivative
Traders uh are handling the merge it's
always fascinating to see like what is
the market doing we know the merge is
coming uh we know that people are uh uh
talking about it we know that it is
going to uh create change whether you
think it's a good change a bad change
whether it's going to prove the point of
the critics or the proponents like
changes coming how are Traders actually
playing this
so you can see but ethereum is the most
hatched asset in the crypto market right
now and that's
um on question and also not surprising
uh you can see it both in the Futures
Market in the in the options market so
in terms of the Futures Market you have
accreditation which is extremely
uncommon for ethereum uh in Bitcoin as
well
um most of this is um the assumption is
especially large large Traders are
um uh hashing their position
um and you know selling contracts and
buying spot therefore
um producing Liquidation in the asset a
major degradation uh in terms of options
you know open interest in that market
cohort is at all time highs even value
in ethereum
um forget about dollar validation so in
terms of ethereum you see that the green
line and the chart there it has been
extremely consistent right
um you pretty much see it go up and then
slightly down as expirations amount over
time since 2020 but since January 2022
you see a a steep increase in ethereum's
open interest you know as the merge gets
priced into
um the the market structure and the
general sentiment in the options Market
and if we stay on this topic for a
second obviously the merge is uh
something that the proponents would look
at as a positive Catalyst but there's
been some negative catalysts as well I
had somebody on the podcast uh who is uh
an attorney he was talking a lot about
First Amendment uh and things around
tornado cash and that brings us to uh
kind of these oh facts sanctions and and
some of the uh uh tools that are being
used to address whether it's in the defy
World um but even a concern that maybe
it will come for privacy uh maybe it
will come for even in the Bitcoin
Community like how do you all think of
these ofax sanctions and and their
efficacy uh in tamping down maybe some
of the excitement or use of these
Technologies
certainly a concern I think fungibility
privacy and therefore responsibility
is uh I believe one one of the the major
concerns regarding World crypto and of
course it applies more to ethereum given
that let's say no fact sanction can
apply to uh State major staking pools in
the system that have to comply with
those uh sanctions
um but it still applies to Bitcoin in
the sense that utxos can get blacklisted
and therefore you can see a
goldification of it uh where you know
certain coins that haven't been involved
with nefarious activity could be deemed
untradable especially under U.S
regulation and therefore Bitcoin uses
fungibility right so those coins or if
or whatever uh lose value right so
instead of trading on market value you
could see them trading ad uh you know 10
discount or whatever the market assigns
to that
we're giving a close uh we're giving a
close eye on that
um we we're especially as the merge
because the transition to produce take
does increase
um that risk especially for ethereum
regardless of being in risk for all
crypto and as we look at this the piece
to me that becomes the most interesting
is you specifically called out
centralization and the ability to resist
some of this uh is a test for
centralization uh how do you guys think
about is there a A Line in the Sand hey
you have to be this decentralized uh is
there a way to measure centralization
versus decentralization uh or is it more
so uh you try to evaluate it given the
information you have but there's no
right answer
um there's great Nuance on that because
you have several dimensions of
decentralization that you have to
consider right you have ownership is one
which I think it's overstated meaning
what what if a single entity owns a lot
of Bitcoin or wreath or whatever and
then dumps on the market still at a
prodigal level it has no effect right it
only has spec on on price activity and
and the market as a whole on a prodigal
level or a game theoretical economic
level it's more concerning so you have
to look ultimately I think
uh so far we have some research on that
coming up uh in in a few months but
ultimately I I believe that the cost to
run a node is the most basic and yet
import or important or fundamental
metric to determine decentralization is
this argument comes from post uh stores
and
um I believe it's
um
crucial to determine the the you know
the possibility of a network getting
attacked in a protocol level why because
the cheaper the node
um the the easier to combat uh an
attacker with a lot of capital right or
hashing power or staking power in the
case of ethereum soon
um so we have research on that uh coming
up in a in in the next few months so
um
we'll let you guys know um as that
publication approaches awesome the last
thing that you touched on in the report
uh which is kind of the talk of all of
financial markets is uh the macro
environment and inflation continues to
uh kind of accelerate
um the FED seems to be relatively
ineffective in getting inflation down
although they are creating tighter
Financial conditions what is your read
or why include this in the report is it
just that the macro environment is kind
of the most important thing right now or
there are other considerations as to uh
how maybe the macro environment and
inflation interact with Bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
in each sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eatsleep.com pump not only do
I sleep on it every night it literally
changed my life and I begged the
founders to let me invest in the company
eight sleep.com go get yourself an eight
sleep pod and get a better night of
sleep
yeah it's important to have the the
macro session like you you can argue
um with
you know High conviction that the macro
uh as the overall
um signal has become extremely if not
the most valuable uh source of
information for the trimming uh Bitcoin
and crypto price action as well uh this
since Corbin the code meltdown March
2020
um this was a period where most of the
price discovery of the asset or crypto
asset especially if it's going ethereum
and therefore through correlation
algorithmic uh trading and all that
crypto us all
this was the moment uh where
institutions especially U.S institutions
started to participate and partake in
you know huge amount of the price action
of Bitcoin on a day-to-day basis uh this
hasn't stopped that's why you've seen
you know the correlation it pretty much
tells you uh what's the
how much of the you know um
the change of one asset is being
impacted or inferred from from another
asset and you've seen this with NASDAQ
and s p being highly correlated analyzed
uh versus Bitcoin and ethereum in the
lab since covered so we're keeping an
eye on that in the general context The
Narrative is pretty much the same
as you guys look at uh the home
inventories you've called out that it is
indicating a recession uh talk a little
bit about uh the idea of a recession uh
obviously we have some folks uh whether
it's at the central bank or or in
politics that say we're not in a
recession look at the labor market look
at other you know data points
um but then folks from the finance
Market they seem to be much more
convinced that yes this is a
recessionary period and and there could
be more pain ahead how do you kind of
just think through this
well that's the the
you know we entitled it uh we
named it uh the fattest between
the rock of inflation hard place of
recession right
there seems to be no on a monetary
policy level there seems to be no way
out of either
inflating prices and crashing the market
and you know uh stagnating growth
severely in the economy so
um sorry about that um so
it it pretty much determines uh Powell's
decision who you know seems to be
evoking a bulker severely in the last
few months
so it seems to be very much
um with a high intent of tampering
inflation
um even at the risk of
uh
um having negative growth and therefore
a very severe recession
uh we believe uh this is the the most
bearish case for the gun at this point
um despite using the engine metrics and
a few technicals we are severely
oversold uh on a cyclical level
despite that the correlation between uh
equities and and crypto is so severe
that we stay cautious
um uh on what what the macro and
therefore you know CPI prints and fed
meetings the German in the months going
forward
and as you think about bitcoin's
performance so far you know is it
holding up compared to the macro
environment or do you feel like you know
it's kind of suffered at the hands of
the FED just like every other asset and
If the Fed continues for another 12
months we should expect more pain in the
Bitcoin Market or how do you kind of
think about that relationship moving
forward
um once in it is just chop until let's
say next year I'm pretty much looking
for Peak inflation right uh
statistically
um equities bottom exactly or a month
before quick inflation right so that's a
a major event we're looking into
um but it's still up in the air when
that happens
um a lot of macro applications going
into that and how the CPI is calculated
and there's a lot of debate on that of
course uh and on top of that how um you
know how Powell determines uh risk on
and risk environments going forward
um now interestingly or specifically for
for Bitcoin
uh an interesting data point that we
found uh on a four-year basis uh if you
take a Target off that meaning a company
annual growth rate on a four-year time
Horizon
uh for the first time Bitcoin after
being between let's say 100
and 2 change percent uh range for about
six years on that gagger that dropped
this year uh for the first time to
between 30 and 100
um so this was expected to some extent
meaning um Bitcoin even the price is an
asker so you're gonna have diminishing
returns so you're going to increase it
at an administrate
um it seems to be
no but for the first time we're noticing
this year
in terms of overall performance metrics
kaggers sharp ratios Etc
um you know Bitcoins uh growth
um still increasing but at a diminished
rate so I I just thought that was uh
interesting overall yeah it's absolutely
fascinating when you guys put these out
where can people find the the monthly
reports that you're going to continue to
do each month
um yeah
um you can
um look for them in
um
arc-invest.com uh we we have a dedicated
crypto section where you can like pretty
much download And subscribe
to to the back on monthly we have
upcoming activity in that section in the
next few months as well so check in from
time time and the working people find
you on Twitter if they want to follow up
with some of the stuff that you said
here or or get more information that you
continue to put out
uh yeah my my handle is a deep well Arc
um
awesome well David listen thank you so
much for uh for for jumping on real
quick uh these reports are you know
they're very fast to read through uh but
they're incredibly High signals so I
appreciate you and our team continue to
put them together I enjoy reading them I
know many other people do as well they
just give a great kind of understanding
of hey here's what's going on uh in the
moment over the last month uh and
they're kind of these great checking
points so if anyone hasn't uh gone and
downloaded them uh highly suggest you do
that follow David on Twitter and then
we'll talk again next month
thanks for having me